[Music]
gabriel's with us in detroit hi gabriel
welcome to the ramsay show
hey uh how are you guys great man what's
up
uh
good news and bad news um
bad news a lot of debt good news uh
aren't you guys
um
the the other bad news is
i was here before um
i was a listener
i i started the baby steps
uh and then probably the last two years
i want to say it just started falling
off
you know the wagon getting back on
credit cards thinking i could pay it by
the end of the month
and that turned into within two years
roughly 35 000 of credit card debt
and i'm at a point where the last six
months it's been extremely difficult to
just maintain so
i
went the route of uh consolidating my
debt and paying this company who would
brokerage a deal
at that point
you know seven months into this program
i'm
extremely skeptical i'm not
as aware as i thought i was what's
happening with with the money and
it's like
i never really had the reins in the
first place but now for sure i don't
have
an idea where the reins are and
i'm pretty much at the
at the point where there's no more
savings
and i have credit card debt did you run
up gabriel
30 35. what do you make a year
i make um
i make about 70 and my wife makes about
uh 25.
okay so you have a hundred and five or
hundred ninety five thousand dollar
household income and thirty thousand
dollars in credit card debt
okay how much is your car debt
uh car debt i have uh thirteen thousand
and what's that card what's that car
worth
um
there's two uh one is a minivan one's a
truck uh the minivan is um
i owe 5700 on it it's roughly
a six thousand dollar minivan the truck
um currently it's
under repair so i'm trying to get it
back on the road but that one is
probably worth um
nine or ten and it's uh
at about seven thousand dollars and dead
on that one
okay
and uh how long you been married
uh married since 09 so um
going on so are you and your you and
your wife um
you sound kind of uh depressed a little
bit
like down in the dumps
yeah that'd be nice
um
are you tired enough of the chaos and
the disorganization to now fix it
finally yeah yeah
and hopefully this time we're good
never go back
absolutely yeah
okay
well i've been where you've been where
you are um i've done stupid and
got the opportunity to live through it
and um you're gonna be okay
but here's the thing there's a
tremendous power
and joy
in taking control again
cleaning up the mess
lining it up and starting to knock it
off one at a time one at a time one at a
time and that's going to involve
canceling your contract with the stupid
debt consolidation people getting the
credit cards out and cutting them up
we're going to get you on a budget
you're going to sell so much stuff the
kids think they're next you're not going
on vacation and you're not going into a
restaurant but you knew i was going to
say all that didn't you
yeah
now the question is are you gonna do it
yeah okay then i'll show you how
we'll get you into financial peace
university hold on kelly i'll sign you
up and i'll pay for it and the two of
you get in there
but by god gabriel this time do it son
do it life's too short to live this day
like this you're getting the crap beat
out of you by this stuff time for you to
stand back up and shake it off move on
to the next thing
i understand am i picking on you for
falling off the wagon but let's go fix
it
last time forever hold on kelly i'll
pick up